why
is pewdiepie the dumbest youtuber
why is pewdiepie the
dumbest ute why is he the dumbest
youtuber
why i demand an answer oh wait there's
the video
that it's right there speaking the truth
one video
at a time hey how's it going bros my
name is wait you can't just sample
one of my videos as your [ __ ] intro
thank you very much
what if i did that to one of your other
videos
oh jesus christ someone is trying hard
[ __ ] hell wanna be a [ __ ] like yoga
pins are so [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
so [ __ ] so [ __ ] so sweaty
okay this person is insane let's see
what she has to say
pewdiepie is the most subscribed to
youtube channel with 37 million
subscribers 46
but this was made in 2015. i'll give you
a pass
what is he doing with those 37 million
subscribers
what is he doing with those 37
million subscribers what is she looking
at when she says that what is he doing
with those
camera's right here you gotta what are
you looking don't so [ __ ]
this is a video this is a video
what the [ __ ] she oh my god
oh my god this is done reasonably
someone discovered the watch time thing
oh my god oh this makes everything so
much better i should have done more
research
the video ends
the video ends at 7 41 but she wanted to
get it more than 10 minutes so she can
add an extra advert ad in there
so she just added the thumbnail
brilliant i'm not even talking about the
video i need to watch the video i'm
sorry what in the [ __ ]
is he doing don't get me wrong i love
the fact that pewdiepie can make a
living off of playing video games you
just answered your own question
as great as it is to have an income from
playing video games
and to have the most subscribed to
channel on youtube what good is it for
what is it for
what why not influence people to stop
exploiting torturing raping and
slaughtering innocent beings for food
wait raping
raping wait wait raping raping did she
say raping
raping for food raping reaping animals
for food raping and slaughtering
if pewdiepie were to go vegan he'd have
a meaningful message
if i went vegan i would have a
meaningful message
are all vegans part of some cult or
something like what's happening
what what about all the charity that i
do we raised over a million dollars
towards
many different charities is that not a
meaningful message enough
or does animals only matter just
confused an additional few million
subscribers
doesn't mean [ __ ] if you're not a vegan
whatever the [ __ ] you've accomplished
it don't matter for [ __ ] this is like
why no one will take vegan seriously
because one
bat [ __ ] crazy person come out and say
stuff like this
and everyone else just gets discredited
if you don't have a core message that's
making a positive impact on the planet
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah what
the [ __ ] am i doing what the [ __ ] are
you doing
god damn it what the [ __ ] am i doing
raising money millions of dollars for
charity what the [ __ ]
am i doing what the [ __ ] are you doing
i'm not a vegan
god damn it i'm not a vegan if you don't
have a core message that's making a
positive impact on the planet
[ __ ] are you doing entertaining millions
of people
for years seriously what the [ __ ] are
you doing
seriously what what the [ __ ] are you
doing
seriously serious seriously
seriously what the [ __ ] are you doing
what the [ __ ] are you doing
aren't you vegan like me man seriously
why aren't you vegan like i am seriously
i am a vegan seriously
all right i am at least 20
percent better than you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] how can you
eat meat you [ __ ] dirty even
cow's milk i [ __ ] spit that [ __ ] in
your [ __ ] how can you not be a vegan man
what the [ __ ] are you doing how can you
not see how blind you
are how can you not [ __ ] understand
what a piece of [ __ ] low-life piece
of [ __ ] you are
seriously what the [ __ ] are you doing i
don't have a core message
if you don't have a poor message
i don't know my core message but i'm
pretty sure what hers is
being for my core message
i need to show as much of my skin as
possible and wear yoga pants
so [ __ ] seriously what the [ __ ] are
you doing go get a core message and make
a positive impact on the planet
she's insane she's insane i'm scared
she will murder me go do it carp the
[ __ ] up hard in the [ __ ] up and go get a
core message
what that's making a positive impact on
the planet go do it right
now go
go stop watching this video and go do it
go do it go find a core message that's
making a positive impact on the planet
go
do it now go now you should be gone why
aren't you gone right now go
do something positive the planet like go
vegan maybe
i don't know it's not like going vegan
isn't positive or anything like that
no go vegan and save the planet
go vegan
nice to animals treat people like [ __ ]
i'm tr i'm i'm 20 better than you
my name is sorsha and
i have nothing to
define me as a human being i have no
actual personality or
anything that makes me stand out from
the crowd and
i can't stand that fact about myself
so i've decided to label myself
as something in an attempt to make me
feel more
valued and to make me feel superior
over other people i am
telling them what a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] they are for not
being up here with me the superior being
who has levitated towards a higher being
and i [ __ ] hate the world
carve the [ __ ] up oh my god do it now
i love how she discovered the 10 minute
mark thing
this is this is making me so happy this
is what you did youtube
this is the kind of [ __ ] that happens
when people understand how the algorithm
work i like how she tells me to find my
own core message but really she's just
telling me
that i'm not a vegan and i i'm a piece
of [ __ ]
thank you very much for helping me find
my core message
i will now go on and tell michael who's
in the other room what a piece of [ __ ]
he is
for not finding his core message and i
would really appreciate that my 47
million subscribers
first you turn vegan and then you find
the person next to you and you tell them
that you're a piece of [ __ ]
who hasn't found their core message
despite any kind of accomplishment or
or abilities that they may have if they
haven't found their core message
tell them that they need to [ __ ] die
tell them that they need to find it or
otherwise they're a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and you are 10 times better than them uh
also let's sample
her yoga pants one more time because she
did that [ __ ] to me
so [ __ ] thank you very much this has
been a pleasure leave a like if you
enjoyed i'll do the brofist
i'll go out we'll add the thumbnail
that's how we do this
thank you both for watching and as
always stay awesome breasts
you